Hello world,
it's Saroj and today I'm going to share
10 strategies I personally use to learn
advanced concepts as fast as possible.
Computer Science is my one true love.
There are endless subtopics to explore
from basic concepts like abstraction to
more advanced concepts like
machine learning, security,
distributed systems and teledildonics
and because I find it so incredibly
exciting.
I love the process of learning it,
which brings me to my first point.
Find a reason to learn before
you start your learning journey.
You've got to have that motivation,
that drive to learn.
That means finding a cause.
You really believe in,
this is my first point because
it's the most important.
Giving yourself the space
to reflect on yourself,
your life and the state of humanity is
one of the most important things you can
do in this regard. That means
traveling, seeking out new experiences,
meeting new and interesting people,
connecting with them,
and really trying to understand their
motivations in life to help you formulate
your own.
For me,
traveling through Asia for a few months
gave me the perspective I needed to
finally realize that solving AI was
the most important thing in the world.
I realized that despite having
failed in so many other tasks,
I was a gifted communicator and I saw
an opportunity to apply my unique skill
set to help achieve this goal,
but once you're ready to learn,
how do you know where to start?
What we're all lucky in that the Internet
provides us with a huge variety of
learning resources that
we could potentially use.
It is the new university and it is
our responsibility to use it as such.
The only way to know which resources work
best for you is to try out as many of
them as you can and
reinforcement learning.
This is called the exploration
versus exploitation dilemma.
How does a learning agent know how
much to explore possible options before
choosing one and utilizing
it to its full capacity?
Different people learn in different ways.
For example,
whenever I'm researching a topic,
I'll Google it and open up at least 10
different browser windows dedicated to
informational links on that
topic simultaneously. Some
of them will be articles,
some will be videos, some will
be papers, some will be podcasts.
I'll quickly skim through each of them
getting as much of the just as I can
before settling on one that I find
especially interesting and retains my
interest longer than the rest.
My personal favorite way of learning
is to watch videos at three x speed on
Youtube. I use a chrome extension to do
this link to it is in the description.
It feels like when neo had data
downloaded it into his brain,
I'm getting both auditory and visual
input into my head at three x the normal
speed. It was hard for my brain to
get used to that much of a speed up,
so I started off only a little faster
and over time gradually increase the
speed.
The brain will adapt.
It will learn to process input faster
and eventually normal speed will feel too
slow. This same logic can apply
to podcasts and audio books.
Don't discount any medium of learning.
The more diverse your inputs,
the better or more generalized your
understanding of a topic will be,
but if you have a bunch of
possible learning options,
you want to start off with the
absolute simplest ones first.
You've got to have a basic understanding
of a topic first before you move on to
the harder stuff.
I usually look for Eli fives on
Reddit for super tough concepts.
Those are really helpful.
Also short introductory explainer
videos on youtube are awesome,
so if I want to learn about say gradient
descent rather than first going through
the scientific paper that
introduces gradient descent
with a bunch of equations,
I'll first try to understand the concept
a very high level and the reasons for
it. Then once I have a basic
idea from a few sources,
I'll read some in depth tutorials from
people who've gone through the process of
learning it already.
The experts,
hopefully with code samples so I
can build off of their knowledge.
It's like a tree of abstractions.
If you can peer into
someone's representation of
a concept in their mind by
consuming their content,
you can grasp that concept much faster.
When it comes to code, I use get
hub like a Google for code samples.
I look for really basic code samples
that don't have too many lines of code,
ideally under a hundred that
programmatically implement some concept.
I'll analyze the architecture and then
move on to a more detailed implementation.
If you start with the hardest stuff first,
it will be way easier to
get discouraged and give up,
so you have to create a set of small
achievable goals in your journey.
Whenever we began the learning process,
we go through a honeymoon phase where we
experienced a release of dopamine as we
encounter novel concepts,
but there is always a dip in excitement,
a period when our progress
slows and we get frustrated.
Many people end their journey at that dip.
They convinced themselves that they
aren't smart enough or they've run out of
money or they'd rather
watch game of Thrones,
but if you can stay motivated
through the dip period,
then eventually you'll get
to the point of mastery,
a place where you can finally feel that
you've learned the topic and be proud of
that fact.
Set deadlines for each of these goals.
The research shows that doing this
motivates you to complete each one.
Breaking up your larger learning goal
into smaller ones will help keep you
motivated.
You're receiving a dopamine reward every
time you've learned some small part of
a larger concept and since each goal
you've created isn't too hard or too easy,
it keeps you interested,
allowing you to maintain a flow state,
a state of maximum
concentration and focus.
Creating your own well-planned learning
path. It doesn't come naturally.
It's a skill and like all skills,
it needs to be homed learning,
which are the right questions to
ask is a really useful exercise.
When designing your learning goals,
what are the burning questions
you'd like to have answered?
Take some time to write them down.
It's surprisingly useful to be able
to see them outside your own head.
Let your curiosity drive their
learning path and it will be a lot more
enjoyable. Learning isn't just about
consuming content, it's about doing.
Studies show that you should spend a
third of your time researching and two
thirds of your time doing.
For example,
you can stare at the chain rule
all day and look at code samples,
but unless you implement it yourself,
you won't truly understand how
backpropagation works. In deep learning.
Doing means finding some medium of
applying what you've learned. For me,
that medium is teaching. I am constantly
writing scripts of what I've learned,
speaking,
reading out those scripts and editing,
adding relevant assets to be
displayed alongside my boys practice.
Finding the most dense
description of a topic you can.
How can you summarize an entire
algorithm into one sentence?
You can also take notes by
hand or create flashcards,
both proven methods for knowledge
retention. But look, let's be real.
Learning advanced concepts isn't easy,
so you've got to allow
yourself to be uncomfortable.
Nothing worth achieving comes easily.
Those experts weren't born
with the knowledge they have.
They put in countless hours
of study to get there.
That uncomfortable feeling you get when
you encounter a topic you know nothing
about is the learning process.
You got to get okay with that discomfort.
Just know that the more you look
at a topic, the easier it'll get.
Your brain behaves like a muscle.
So you've got to train it like one,
just like how the best
athletes train every morning,
no matter how sore they feel or
the best writers write every day,
no matter how bad it turns out,
the best students know that.
It's all about having a
disciplined study regimen.
There are so many potential
distractions out there.
You have to have the discipline to tune
out everything else and focus on your
task. Do it in intervals, every 50
minutes. Give yourself some intense,
highly focused learning time.
Take a 10 minute break and repeat and
because the learning process can be
difficult,
remember to seek out feedback.
If you have a question that you're
having a really hard time answering,
ask it on stack overflow or a
sub reddit or a slack channel.
Ask a friend,
find someone you really admire who excels
in that topic and ask them on Twitter
directly.
You'll find that most people are more
than willing to help you out if you ask a
question in a short, concise and
easily digestible way. And lastly,
take care of yourself. That means treat
your body like the machine that it is.
You've only got one.
That means avoid too much sugar or
remember to eat fruits and vegetables and
find a fun way to exercise,
jogging, biking, fencing,
anything that will improve
blood circulation to your
brain at least three times
a week. Anyways, I hope
my tips helped you.
I've summarized them all in the video
description below and no coding challenge
this week.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos and for now I've got to feel to
learn,
so thanks for watching.